[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Y was born out of pain it was never
an academic or commercial exercise it
was born out of a time in my life many
years ago 10 years ago where I had lost
my passion for what I was doing I own my
own small business I was living the
American dream
superficially my life was fantastic and
yet I didn't want to wake up and do it
again and I was embarrassed by that you
know who am I to complain about my life
my life seemed perfect and yet I hated
it and so I kept it to myself every
ounce of my being every all the energy
that I had was invested in pretending
that I was happier more successful and
more of control than I felt and it was
debilitating quite frankly strange
things start to happen when you put
yourself in that cycle and the stress
starts to build you start to become
paranoid so for example I was convinced
that um my employees hated me I didn't
go out much and it was really it was
really a bad time and it was until a
friend of mine came to me concerned that
I wasn't acting myself and basically
offered me nothing more than moral
support what if you need I got your back
and worried about you and it was that
simple act that gave me the courage to
face my own problem and was that simple
act that gave me the courage to seek out
a solution to go back to the way I used
to feel to be passionate about something
again there was a confluence of events
and I made this discovery that every
single organization on the planet even
our own career is always function on the
same three levels what we do how we do
it and why we do it and it was based on
the biology of human decision-making it
wasn't some highfalutin management
theory was based on brain stuff and I
realized I knew what I did it was good
at it and I knew how I did it I could
tell you what was different or special
about the way I did things but I
couldn't tell you why I was doing it
that was the missing piece you have to
have all three I became obsessed with
this thing called the why I figured out
how to find my why and it restored my
passion to levels I had never
experienced before and more importantly
I figured out how to help
find theirs and I did what anyone would
do when you discover something beautiful
you share with your friends and my
friends started making crazy life
changes themselves and they started
finding happiness and passion that they
never experienced before it was me
solving my own problem that happened to
help others solve it for them too and
people just kept inviting me and I just
kept saying yes I was making huge
decisions that were really easy to make
like I shut down my office and started
over again because I realized the
business I had built was so inconsistent
with my why all my friends thought I
went out of business they were worried
about me it was the easiest easiest
decision I ever made
in other words when you know your why
the filter is clear it's not like there
are options the option is obvious
there's only one option share give
inspire and everything that I've
achieved any success that I've enjoyed
has all been a hundred percent because
of the gracious just amazing generosity
of people around me my friends my
colleagues people who just believe what
I believe they are the ones who either
introduced me to others or took a risk
or said let me try that or bought a book
or watched a TED talk or more
importantly sent it to somebody else
because they thought they would be
inspired by it for all of the things
that I've done over the past decade I
still feel like I'm at the beginning I
have been saying it for 10 years
when everybody says to me you know
congratulations on X Y or Z my answer is
always the same tip of the iceberg and I
think that's what keeps me inspired
which is for me it's a journey I'm on
the right path I'm walking past the
right mile markers in other words I know
making progress to the vision that I
have to build this world in which the
vast majority of people wake up every
single morning inspire to go to work
feel safer in their their returning home
at the end of the day fulfilled by the
work that they do when I started the
race I ran by myself and it's lonely
alone alone
and now I don't like it here like a
thousand people to the left of people to
the right the thousand people behind me
and I look around I'm like yeah we're
gonna change the world
we're going to change the world there
you go
[Music]
Matthew
[Music]
you